rendez vous compte le chef aura formé en
soixante dix ans plus de 18 mille
diplômés
le chef fête ses 70 ans samedi dernier
le centre horticole d'enseignement et de
promotion ouvrait ses portes au public
l'établissement est spécialisée dans la
formation aux métiers de l'aménagement
paysager mais aussi de la protection de
la nature on dispense donc des cours en
matière générale les cours des matières
générales donc avec d une approche un
peu théorique et puis ensuite on réalise
sur le terrain donc tous les chalets
dire tous les acquis tous les acquis
théoriques
le programme du chef a connu de
nombreuses évolutions se calquant sur
les attentes du moment mais aussi en
anticipant les impératifs de demain les
métiers ont énormément évolué nous
étions au départ sur l'horticulture
ensuite sur du paysage aujourd'hui sur
de paysages et de l'environnement
bien sûr nous répondons aux besoins des
professionnels mais également aux
besoins de la société où la place de
l'environnement et de la protection de
la nature est de plus en plus prégnante
le centre de formation ne perd pas de
vue son futur le projet campi val qui
mutualisera le chef et deux autres
centres de formation mais aussi le
projet d'un hébergement qui accueillera
jusqu'à 1000 élèves verront bientôt le
jour